Robin je vais vous dire moi j'ai enquêté
et voilà ce que les gens m'ont dit c'est
de la décence assez précipité à
l'hôpital sachez-le dès le vendredi soir
quand il était annoncé grièvement blessé
son pronostic vital engagé elle a
attendu de savoir qu'il était hors de
danger pour partir sans savoir qu'il y
avait des victimes et qu'il était
responsable elle a elle savait pas comme
nous elle a pris l'histoire au fur et à
mesure comme nous tous dès le lendemain
surtout le dimanche quand elle a su sa
terrible responsabilité les victimes
dans le coma le bébé décédé elle n'a pas
pu le supporter moralement sachez-le et
on peut la comprendre Muriel que c'est
que on s'aime beaucoup Muriel et moi
voilà c'est quelqu'un voilà que
j'apprécie beaucoup et je la comprends
et elle est extrêmement de rien
fragilisée par cette affaire elle est
très très touchée par l'état des blessés
la prise de stupéfiants et ce que dit
Muriel Robin je vous dis c'est que un
moment elle aime son ami mais elle peut
plus pardonner un moment voilà là elle
est dans un truc où MML et elle est pas
comme nous tous ici on est on avait on
est on aimait tous faire Palmade ici on
est venu nous voir plein de fois et
c'est vrai que on a
on avait tous envie même quand il est
venu il a envie de l'aider mais voilà un
moment c'était une amitié fusionnelle de
35 ans qui a volé en éclat sachez-le
elle a tout essayé pour le sortir de ses
addictions avec d'autres très proches je
vous le même je vous le dis même il
savait même fait des réunions voilà avec
des proches avec Pierre Palmade ses amis
très proches ils avaient fait des
réunions pour
l'obliger à partir en cure pour
l'obliger à se soigner il faisait
régulièrement parce qu'ils avaient peur
pour lui ils avaient peur qu'il arrive
un drame malheureusement le drame mais
c'est plus qu'un drame qui est arrivé et
Muriel elle a rien pu faire et elle est
très très touchée sachez-le moralement
Muriel Robin que j'embrasse parce
qu'elle a rien à voir là dedans et quand
je vois des gens sur les réseaux sociaux
qui s'attaquent à elle qui s'en prennent
à elle qui la met dans une sauce dans
laquelle n'est pas du tout ça me rend
fou je vous le dis si je trouve ça
inadmissible et je vous le dis je vous
le redis Muriel elle pensait à son ami
et elle a maintenu maintes fois
organiser des réunions c'est elle qui
organisé des réunions pour lui dire
pierre ça va être un drame faut que tu
nous écoutes un moment une fois deux
fois ça fait 10 réunions à un moment
elle peut pas être à sa place donc je
vois des gens qui mettent Muriel dans la
sauce ça me rend fou je vous dis et
c'est vraiment c'est tout ce que je
déteste c'est vraiment ça me dégoûte
c'est voilà ils essaient de s'en prendre
à tout le monde c'est la chasse aux
sorcières autour de Pierre Palmade et à
un moment elle romain c'est son ami à
Pierre Palma ça a toujours été son ami
elle n'a pas laissé tomber comme je vous
l'ai dit elle était à l'hôpital
donc elle y va direct est-ce précipite
pour savoir ce qui s'est passé après
derrière elle apprend tout le truc elle
se dit bah moi voilà mes mails et je dis
je
je sais pas voilà mais
elle est triste et surtout elle se dit
je ne peux plus le défendre il est
indéfendable et aujourd'hui elle a pas
envie de s'exprimer là-dessus parce que
forcément elle est extrêmement touchée
imaginez-vous si votre meilleur ami à
qui vous avez dit matin faut arrêter tes
conneries il va avoir un drame tu vas
dans le mur et à un moment il se passe
un drame vous savez qu'il est
responsable en plus
[Musique]
aux familles des victimes bien sûr elle
a pas envie de s'exprimer aussi de dire
voilà par rapport aux familles des
victimes je vous dis c'est de la décence
aussi c'est ce qu'elle dit j'ai pas
envie de m'exprimer c'est aujourd'hui ce
qui se dit Muriel Robin c'est que la
priorité c'est pas que je m'exprime
c'est que les gens aillent mieux voilà
donc je vous dis aujourd'hui je vois le
procès de Muriel Robin sur les réseaux
et je trouve ça nul voilà je vous le dis
et elle a tout fait pour l'aider
sachez-le voilà je vous le dis je source
sûre maintenant voilà si vous voulez
dire un mot mais je voulais pas faire
ne pas s'exprimer je suis tout à fait
d'accord bah oui en revanche je sais
quelle est leur relation mais ne plus
soutenir non si c'est son ami c'est pour
ça je ne sais pas ne plus soutenir
à ton ami que je te donne c'est des
infos sur Oui pas des est-ce que oui
voilà moi ce que je te donne c'est des
infos ce que je dis voilà les inconnus
et oui mais soutenir oui elle doit
soutenir son ami les infos que je te
donne elles sont sûrs
quoi moi je soutiens Muriel Robin c'est
tout bah oui bah bien sûr exceptionnel
du début jusqu'à la fin quoi faire
d'autre en fait elle a une bonne Muriel
et et c'est indispensable
elle sait comme je l'aime et Muriel
Robin un moment elle peut plus rien
faire un moment qu'on t'a tout fait pour
ton pote et que tu lui as dit 15 fois je
vous dis ça c'est vraiment un une info
que je vous donne qui est sorti une part
qui faisait des réunions autour de
permanence que vous rendez compte que
ses potes à Pierre Palmade ils se
réunissaient pour lui dire oh il se
disait il s'appelait il faut qu'on voit
pierre parce que là ça va partir en
cacahuète
tu décompte ou pas ça c'est un truc de
fou déjà déjà je trouve que les potes
ils ont été là
ils ont été plus que là à un moment il
faut se mettre à sa place elle est très
très touchée par cette affaire par
contre elle perd mine de rien elle perd
son père son enfin elle perd entre
guillemets son meilleur pote c'est c'est
vrai c'est c'est dur c'est meilleur pote
tu es dans une sauce parce que tu te dis
dans ta tête à un moment Muriel elle
doit se dire aussi bah peut-être que
j'ai pas fait ce qu'il fallait est-ce
que j'aurais pas dû être plus présente
est-ce que j'aurais pas un moment je
vous disais des coups des choses aussi
qu'elle a peur de découvrir
ceux qui s'abandonnent ça fait beaucoup
pour elle c'est vrai aussi et donc voilà
je vous dis et je le redis sur les
réseaux sociaux il faut un peu la lâcher
Muriel Robin j'aimerais le Robin elle
est dans aucune sauce sachez-le elle a
fait ce qu'il fallait maintenant elle
pense qu'à une chose je vous dis c'est
elle est victime et père Palmade un
moment elle se dit bah que ce que
j'aurais pu faire j'aurais peut-être pu
faire mieux pour mon ami mais
malheureusement le le drame est arrivé